i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington we have a very big show
for you tonight anna's canter freedom is
here with an exclusive that will expose
how the nba is again doing china's
bidding plus
cattle mutilations in mike pence in the
same segment what
we're going to see how that one goes
tucker carlson is staying up late to be
here
the swamp though gerds for 2024. that's
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
now just for a few moments i want you to
stop and think about what the elites and
their media valets want you to believe
because they make one outlandish claim
after another like how an incumbent who
loses her primary by 37 points
is actually a winner
liz cheney
it seems so quick to say a profile in
courage but she really is and i respect
enormously the fact that she spoke out
for the truth cheney's future is yet to
be written
or the lie that 8.5 inflation is really
zero inflation
or a law with 437 billion in new
spending can reduce inflation just by
its name alone
or i love this the claim that men can be
mothers and women fathers
can you help me get a good definition of
birthing people
well i'll i'll check on the language
there but i think if we're talking about
those who give birth i think we're
talking about
uh
i i don't know how else to explain it to
you other than
it
or their insistence that pumping
children full of hormones is gender
affirming
every major medical association agrees
gender affirming care is life-saving
medically necessary
age appropriate and a critical tool for
health care providers
i like that smock she's wearing and no
surprise that they think having drag
queens mingling with children is totally
normal
drag queens are just here to
entertain
we can read we're intelligent like we um
we are harmless and i just hope that you
know moving forward it kind of just like
stretches those
imaginations a little bit more to
continue normalizing it
and their dangerous claim that babies
and young kids need covert vaccines to
be safe
the united states is now the first
country in the world to offer safe and
effective covet 19 vaccines for children
as young as 6 months old finally some
peace of mind yeah we wouldn't have
peace of mind without that and of course
they demand that you believe that the
country this country we love
is systemically racist
of course that our borders are closed
when in fact millions of migrants have
walked right in
and one of my favorites that the afghan
withdrawal was correctly handled
we are in a stronger position as a
country because of the president's
decision to weep
and of course even with all those
unabashed lies they claim to be the only
country's serious defenders of democracy
i believe that donald trump continues to
pose a very grave threat and risk to our
republic future of democracy on the
ballot i fear for our democracy and the
republicans forever to get the gamble we
can't let that happen
and of course just like all of their
other grandiose claims this one is dead
wrong in fact the opposite is true
because we're the true defenders of
democracy and they are its enemies
the populist movement has been on the
march ever since the rise of the tea
party back in 2009.
at no point have we
ever gotten the support from the media
or big business hollywood silicon valley
we face overwhelming opposition from the
permanent bureaucracy that staffs the
federal government too
so our power comes entirely from our
ability to convince the voters to
support our ideas
in other words no movement relies more
on democracy and fights harder for it
than we do
it was the votes of the people who
nominated donald trump in 2016
and it was the voters who defeated liz
cheney last night
well we trust the people and everything
we do is designed to give them more
power
but to cheney in her cheering section
the voters they're just useful idiots
the problem the republican party has is
they got really stupid people that vote
in their primaries really stupid people
demand to have really stupid leaders and
that's where the republican party is now
of course they also claim that the
populists are threats to democracy
because they pointed out that there were
election irregularities then of course
january 6 happened
but only a small number of people really
out of the millions and millions who are
america firsters took illegal actions
during that riot and we've consistently
maintained that those people should
suffer appropriate legal consequences
and since when does the desire to
safeguard the integrity of elections
qualify as being anti-democratic in fact
it's the contrary
you see we respect democracy enough that
we want to make sure that elections are
decided by clear and accurate vote
counts
our agenda empowers the average american
we were the first ones to question our
country's relationship with china and
also to insist that it shouldn't be so
easy to just ship american jobs overseas
we were the only ones to insist that
being an american citizen should have
real meaning and real benefits and
therefore that the borders have to be
enforced
we stand up to the teachers unions in
the name of working class parents we
stand up for small businesses threatened
by crime
this is and always has been a movement
for the little guy not the plutocrats or
the bureaucrats who already have too
much power
so if you care about democracy and you
want the voters to have a real say in
policy
you got to join our movement
right now according to real clear
politics over 70 percent of americans
believe this country is on the wrong
track
but it doesn't have to be this way
because we have policies that work and
that make lives better for the average
person we know this
they're working in places like florida
texas tennessee iowa south dakota many
other states
the elites don't trust you and they
certainly don't want to empower you
for them a democracy is where the voters
do what the bureaucrats tell them to do
but for us
it's the other way around
and for almost 14 years this movement
has been growing
cheney's out now let's keep going
in all 50 states
because in our movement no state is left
behind
that's the angle hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else